this video is brought to you by
innovative language the creators of
Indonesian pod 101 and Filipino pod 101
click the link in the description to
check out their huge collection of audio
and video lessons for students of all
levels hello everyone welcome to the
Lang focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to compare Tagalog
otherwise known as Filipino the lingua
franca of the Philippines and Indonesian
the lingua franca of Indonesia the most
widely spoken variety of Malay basically
everything I say about Indonesian in
this video will also apply to Malay
because their standard forms are very
close to each other aside from some
different vocabulary but since I'm more
familiar with Indonesian the samples in
this video will focus on Indonesian
Tagalog on the one hand and Indonesian
and other forms of Malay on the other
are not mutually intelligible but native
speakers of either language often say
that they feel they should be able to
understand the other language but they
can't this is probably due to their
similar pronunciation and intonation and
they might also hear some similar words
in the other language partly because of
the common origins of the two languages
Malay including Indonesian since they're
essentially the same language and
Tagalog are both members of the
malayo-polynesian branch of the
Austronesian language family
that means they developed from the same
language proto malayo-polynesian from
which all members of that branch
descended speakers of proto
malayo-polynesian first migrated from
Taiwan to northern Luzon in the
Philippines before spreading out across
much of maritime Southeast Asia in the
Pacific
most of the languages of Philippines in
most of the languages of Malaysia and
Indonesia outside of Papua that is also
descended from proto malayo-polynesian
so at the core Malayan Tagalog are
related though they've been diverging
from each other for at least 4000 years
and maybe much longer during that time
they've developed their own features and
have undergone different influences
influences on Malay Sanskrit had a heavy
influence on Malay vocabulary and
literature beginning in the 7th century
followed by Arabic in the 14th century
once Islam was established in the
archipelago later on Malay was
influenced by English in bread
colonial territories and Dutch in the
Dutch colonial territories modern
Indonesian which began to be called
Indonesian only in 1928 contains more
Dutch influence while Malay in Malaysia
Brunei and Singapore contains more
English influence influences on Tagalog
one of the major influences on Tagalog
was actually Malay which served as a
lingua franca throughout maritime
Southeast Asia for centuries so some of
the similarities between Malay and
Tagalog stem from their ancient common
origin and some of their similarities
stem from the more recent influence of
Malay on Tagalog then the Spanish
arrived in Philippines in 1521 and left
a massive footprint on Tagalog and other
Filipino languages what percentage of
tagalog words come from Spanish
estimates ranged from 20 percent to 33
percent
this definitely accounts for a lot of
the difference in vocabulary between
Tagalog and Malay and Indonesian
Philippines also became a colony of the
United States for several decades
beginning in 1898 and as a result
English is the second official language
of Philippines and Tagalog has many
borrowings from English since I'm
focusing on Indonesian for the samples
I'm simply going to refer to it as
Indonesian from now on rather than
saying Indonesian and Malay all the time
generally speaking Indonesian and
Tagalog are fairly different in terms of
grammar and sentence structure in terms
of pronunciation they're quite similar
stop consonants in both Indonesian and
Tagalog are unaspirated meaning that
there's no puff of air after the
consonant the way they're often is after
Putta and cut in English they both also
lack and sounds except for a small
number of lone words but many speakers
will pronounce them as bah and bah they
also have similar sets of vowels Tagalog
has 500 an Indonesian has 5 vowel
letters but with 6 sounds because E is
pronounced two ways either as F or as a
schwa in terms of vocabulary the
majority of words are different but
there are also many similar words
including many common basic core words
for example some personal pronouns and
family vocabulary are similar the words
4i
Acco you singular cow cow cow gah
we come me Tammy kita kita in Indonesian
this is we including the listener and
the Tagalog this means me to you or we
in the duel you and me together child
cannot a not male the lucky lucky lucky
malaki
there are also numerous words related to
household and everyday life Bowl mangu
mong kok mosquito net Colombo Colombo
you'll notice that often times where
there's an O sound in one language
there will be an O sound in the other
door been to pinto bean to one table
major Meza the Tagalog word is a Spanish
loan and they also say La Mesa the
Indonesian and Malay word is also a loan
from Portuguese Meza ladle end o Sun
dock and in Malay and Indonesian this
also means spoon nature words rock or
stone but to battle wind onion honey sky
Lang it land fire a P a boy you'll
notice that e at the end of a word in
Malay and Indonesian sometimes
corresponds to a in Tagalog pig Bobby
Bob boy crocodile
Booya Booya numbers and units of time
moon or month bulan one week mingu lingo
the tagalog word comes from the Malay
word and the Malay word is from
Portuguese to mingu year
Sehun Sehun for em but Appa 5 Lima Lima
6 nom I mean thousand rebou libo parts
of the body i mata mata face Mucca Mucca
brain otaku
basic states and emotions hope ASSA ASSA
sick or sickness suck it suck it
delicious
hood up Sara in Tagalog this is the most
common word you see in advertisements
and so on
in Indonesian aina is more common to be
afraid that good pac-12 laughs now wa
taala salamat safety
selamat in tagalog it's basic meaning is
thank you
whereas in Malay and Indonesian it's
often used in greetings like selamat
pagi meaning good morning
other basic verbs to read bacha basa
enter ma su paso it's worth pointing out
that ma and pas are both bilabial sounds
they are both articulated with your lips
together so it would be easy for one
sound to gradually change into the other
to drink
minam you know to open booka booka to
help all along
do you of course I've been intentionally
pointing out words that are similar but
I want to be clear that most words are
not the same so let's look at some
sentences in either language so that we
can compare their sentence structures
but we can also see a more
representative sample of their
vocabulary in general these sentences
mean my child likes cats first in
Indonesian and naaku suka Kuching word
for word it's child my like cats and in
Tagalog mahi League kanako-sama Pusa
word for word it's like focus marker
child my to plural marker cat one part
here seems similar
I'm not qu Hanako but we could change
this word here Pusa - could be me which
means kitten then the sentences will be
even more similar we can see that
Indonesian is basically SVO at its core
sv o Tagalog is basically VSO but
another way to think of it is as
predicate subject because it's not
always a verb in this position in fact
this word here mahi league is not
actually a verb it's an adjective
meaning fond of but a verb would appear
here in the same position basically
these two pieces of the sentence are
versed in Indonesian and Tagalog that's
the more common and natural word order
in Tagalog but there's also an inverted
word order that's more similar to
Indonesian but is generally considered
less natural and is used less often
Nicole I'm a heel eat salmon aku D the
subject here uh Nicole comes at the
beginning followed by the inversion
marker
I followed by the predicate this is less
common and more formal but probably more
intuitive for an Indonesian speaker and
for English speakers as well
notice that the tagalog sentence has
this word that the Indonesian sentence
doesn't have on a focus marker this
comes before the focus of the sentence
whether it's the subject or the object
another thing the Indonesian sentence
doesn't have is a plural marker like
Maga in Indonesian the plural can be
shown with reduplicating like reaching
Kuching but it's not always used of
course Indonesian also lacks an
inversion marker like the word I in
Tagalog in general Tagalog features more
little function words and particles than
Indonesian does especially standard
Indonesian colloquial Indonesian has
some more little words like that
verbs one difference between Indonesian
and Tagalog verbs is that in Indonesian
they have no conjugations for tense or
aspect while Tagalog verbs are
conjugated for aspect though neither
language has different conjugations for
person and number let's look at a quick
example with Indonesian masa and Tagalog
pisaq meaning enter these sentences mean
he entered the school in Indonesian dia
Masuka sekolah and in tagalog bumaba
casa escuela
in the Tagalog verb there's an infix M
which is used for completed actions but
there's nothing like that in the
Indonesian verb if we want to talk about
an action that's happening now
like he's entering the school it's like
this in Indonesian dia Saddam Asuka
sekolah and in tagalog bumaba sock
chasse escuela if we want to talk about
an action that hasn't happened yet
like he will enter the school it's like
this in Indonesian dia akan masuka's
Cola and in together pop a sock chasse
squelen
notice that in Indonesian the verb
itself doesn't change but rather an
aspect marker comes before the verb and
it may be left out
the context makes it clear already in
Tagalog the verb itself is inflected
differently you may also notice that
some of the Tagalog inflections are in
fixes in the first case M and in the
second case there's a doubling of the
first syllable followed by the in fixing
of M Indonesian verbs do not have in
fixes
there are numerous prefixes and suffixes
which change the meaning of the verb in
different ways for example by making it
transitive or causative or passive but
there's nothing for tense or aspect
actor focus and patient focus in tagalog
verbs are either actor focus or patient
focus that means they have different
conjugations depending on whether the
focus of the sentence is on the doer of
the action or the receiver of the action
for example the student read a science
book boumaaza a mr. John teen and
Ibrahim this is actor focus so the focus
is on the student the doer of the action
the NASA young is the Jonte on Libra
Saga a student read the science book
this is patient focus so the focus is on
liberal the receiver of the action you
can see that the verb inflections that
are in fixed to the root are different
for actor focus and patient focus you
can also see that there are two words
that are switched in either sentence
hung and none hung is the in focus
marker and none is the out of focus
marker as a quick side note I should
point out that the noun with the in
focus marker hung is often interpreted
as definite
whereas the noun with the out of focus
marker is often interpreted as
indefinite but definiteness can be
changed by adding additional words like
isang meaning one and it can also be
understood from context based on what
has been previously mentioned Indonesian
doesn't exactly have actor focus and
patient focus like Tagalog does it does
have something similar but simpler a
distinction between subject focus and
object focus subject focus is the basic
type of sentence like this sentence
meaning a student read a science book
Massa SWA Mombasa Bocuse is technically
Indonesian has no definite or indefinite
articles so the nouns here could also be
considered definite but we could more
explicitly
press definiteness by adding Nia which
means it's to either noun or to both
maja see Sonya Mombasa Baku signs Nia or
you could use the demonstrative pronoun
new meaning that object focus usually
places the object first Baku signs
debauch amasi Sonya a science book was
read by the student alternatively this
could be Baku science young you betcha
Massa Sonya a science book is what the
student read notice that an Indonesian
there are no markers that show focus or
lack of focus like there are in Tagalog
we usually know whether its subject
focus or object focus based on which one
comes first in an object focused
sentence in the third person
the prefix D attaches to the verb but in
the first and second person any prefix
is dropped from the verb fukusa in
science i Abacha a science book is what
I read notice that the verb bachi
doesn't have its usual prefix mum
because the sentences object focus and
it doesn't have the prefix D because
that's only for a third person in
Tagalog all the personal pronouns are
different depending on whether they are
in focus or out of focus the out of
focus ones are actually a genitive
pronouns because they're also used as
possessives
in Indonesian most personal pronouns are
the same regardless of whether they are
the focus of the sentence or not as you
can probably see Tagalog on the one hand
and Indonesian and Malay on the other
clearly have some similar features that
show that they are related such as their
similar pronunciation and similar core
basic vocabulary but it's also obvious
that they have diverged so much that
they are not mutually intelligible with
each other
partly because of their different
sentence structure and partly because of
their largely different vocabulary it's
worth remembering that Tagalog is just
one language of the Philippines and that
there are many languages spoken in
Indonesia and Malaysia peaking countries
like Malaysia and Brunei as well tagalog
and Malayan Indonesian are not
necessarily the two most similar
languages from those countries the
question of the day for speakers of
Tagalog and Malay and Indonesian how
well do you understand speakers of the
other language do you understand any
do you recognize some words when you
hear the other language let us know in
the comments down below if you're
interested in learning Indonesian or
Filipino I recommend you click the link
in the description to check out
Indonesian pod 101 or Filipino pod 101
they have hundreds of audio and video
lessons with full transcripts for
students of all levels sign up for a
free account and give it a try and a
special thanks goes out to my patreon
supporters especially these ones right
here on the screen
they are my top tier patreon supporters
and that's why there in the video so
many special thanks to them and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice day
[Music]